I want to welcome you back to the David
Pacman show I am Jesse dalamore filling
in for David while he is out hopefully
resting and relaxing this week
Let's Talk About Kevin McCarthy let's
talk about Congress in general and the
the budget battle that we're facing and
the the debt ceiling battle that we're
facing
we can set aside the fact that
Republicans uh approved uh an in the the
debt ceiling fight they they went
through it and they approved a debt
selling increase for for three times
under Donald Trump When Donald Trump was
President three times no problem oh yeah
it's not a big deal that's it's the
responsible thing to do when there's a
republican in office
but when a Democrat is in office then oh
no no we we need to we're gonna shut
down the government if you don't bend
and bow to our demands
again because it's not about governance
it's not what's best for the full faith
and credit of the United States of
America it's not about any of that it's
about scoring political points it's
about chaos in the system
and Kevin McCarthy was just at the White
House and
um had a meeting with Joe Biden
he comes out of the meeting and is
peppered with questions for several
minutes by reporters and there's one
question in in particular that I really
want to hone in on because
one Kevin McCarthy's
woefully and adequately uh suited for
this job he's not real bright he's not
very articulate and he just generally
kind of fumbles around in the dark for
an answer
the second clip will really really
illustrate that but let's start with
this first question I don't know how
well you're going to be able to hear the
audio so I'll just I'll ask the question
then then you'll be able to piece it
together when you hear the reporter ask
it it's what credibility do
conservatives and Republicans have when
they talk about reducing the debt and
deficits when in the previous
administration when Republicans had
control of both the White House and
Congress they ran up the bill
and this there's no way to disagree with
the premise of these questions this is
fact
when Republicans have been in office
they run away deficits go crazy the
national debt soars
now these are metrics that you can argue
whether they're important or not I I
don't generally think a large national
debt makes that much difference
but
let's set that aside we'll just set that
aside
the fact of the matter is Donald Trump
with his irresponsible unpaid for tax
cuts wasn't able to fund the government
and every all the spending that needed
to be done and his tax cuts resulted in
they were promised that they would be
paid for they promised it would spark
the economy so much that uh it would
just be cash hand over fist into the
treasury
the fact of the matter the the the the
data the the the actual reality is that
there were one trillion and one and a
half trillion dollar deficits 1
000 billion dollar deficits
and one and a half uh and fifteen a
hundred billion dollar deficits every
year of Donald Trump's
presidency
making it so that Donald Trump is
responsible personally as his
administration for 25
of our overall national debt and the
Goof was only in office for four years
pales in comparison it makes Reagan's
Administration and the the wild rampant
spending looked like Child's Play
but let's let's get to this question
from the reporter and listen to Kevin
McCarthy's answer and uh we'll talk
about it on the other side
that's a great question
um when Republicans have control of both
the White House and Congress uh ran up
the bill okay let's just go by the the
sheer facts and figures all right so
Republicans were in the majority for
eight years and the Democrats came in
the majority for the last four years so
in the last four years the Democrats
have increased discretionary spending by
30 percent over 400 billion dollars when
the Republicans were a majority twice
that long the discretionary spending
didn't go up one dollar it went down 10
billion so I think that the credibility
lasts easily with the Republicans if you
want to argue about from a place where
the president the the past president
um if you continue down the same path
this presidency will spend and put us in
debt much greater than before so look
I'm not in a place that I'm going to
point fingers I'm in a place of being
the Speaker of the House
my role right now is to make sure we
have a sensible responsible ability
to raise the debt ceiling but not
continue this runaway spending this is a
moment in time that for All American
households every family does this every
business does this every state
government every County government when
they have spent too much
they Reign back look where waste is at
look where Investments would be better
and sit down and talk in an adult
fashion that's the conversation I just
had with the president and that's the
conversation I want to continue so we
can come to an agreement
why didn't you have those conversations
while Donald Trump was president
why didn't you identify those areas that
are now so important that you're willing
to shut down the government over them
Kevin McCarthy
and all of the ancillary nonsense that
you bring up doesn't defeat the points
that when Donald Trump was in office
prior to becoming president when he
spoke to Bob Woodward with the
Washington Post and said the audacious
claim that he was going to pay off the
entirety of the United States debt
inside of eight years
and instead jacked it up went crazy
spending not raising enough money into
the treasury through tax cuts
that by the way didn't Sunset they
sunseted for the middle class they
didn't sunset
for the rich
this just it's hypocrisy and it's excuse
making and he's stumbling and bumbling
and trying to find a point
and only Republicans fall for this
because it's it's nonsense and it's
propagated this propaganda by right-wing
media Outlets
now getting back to the point earlier
about how he is unfit to be speaker that
he's not qualified or capable of being
speaker listen listen there's a lot of
word salad politicians in Washington
many come to mind one not in Washington
maybe Chief among them is Sarah Palin
but there's a lot of them out there
George W Bush was famous for his word
salad
this sentence I challenge you
to
to explain to me in my feeble brain what
the hell he is talking about listen to
this I believe in hearing both
perspectives like anything else be it
business be it in family being in
relationships that you can find common
ground there's nothing in there but me
walking away that does not believe at
the end of the day we can come to an
agreement
foreign
did you
catch that because I sure didn't I have
no idea what he's talking about let's
read it again
there's nothing in there but me walking
away that does not believe at the end of
the day we can come to an agreement
there's nothing in there but me walking
away that does not believe at the end of
the day we can come to an a
agreement
like make it make sense
please
it's not it's not a rhetorical question
please it's not a rhetorical request
please make it make sense
he's just not fit he's not ready
I mean that we we have many damaging
speakers of the house over the course of
the history of our country even more
modern times Newt Gingrich comes to mind
but they were articulate they could find
a complete sentence with with uh with
but one hand and and Kevin McCarthy is
just incapable
and it's uh it's going to hurt you it's
going to hurt America overall because
he's going to allow the the inmates to
run the prison he already is letting
that happen with Marjorie Taylor green
and while he's uh running over the White
House to to make a big to do about his
negotiation
nothing's getting done other than you
know some real damage that may be
irreparable